Speaker 1: Well, a criminal investigation has
been opened into Florida Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis stunt wherein he paid to fly 50
migrants from Texas to the Massachusetts island
of Martha's Vineyard. And wow, how quickly this
is all developed. Think back to the beginning
when we first found out that Ron DeSantis,
remember Ron DeSantis, governor of Florida,
paid millions of dollars in taxpayer money to
fly migrants from Texas to Martha's Vineyard.
We thought, well, it's a very stupid and brazen
and tasteless political stunt, but that's as far
as it goes, at least potentially. We then learned,
oh, you know, the migrants were lied to. They were
promised things. They were promised that they were
being taken to Boston for expedited something or
rather and help getting jobs and whatever else
the case may be. That's not true. You know,
that's sort of like fraudulent human trafficking.
Maybe there's something criminal there.
And yesterday on the show, I had three or four
different commentaries from lawyers saying, yeah,
this actually does seem like it's a crime. These
were folks that were trafficked illegally by Ron
DeSantis and those deputized by Ron DeSantis for
this stunt. So that where we left that yesterday
was what next? Is there an investigation? What
happens next? And now, indeed, there is a criminal
investigation that has been opened. The Miami
Herald reporting Texas sheriff will investigate
Florida flying a Venezuelan migrants to Martha's
Vineyard. We have video, in fact, of Bexar County
Sheriff Javier Salazar, who explained what
his investigation is going to be and remember.
DeSantis is in Florida, but he decided
to get involved with Texas. And that's
why the sheriff is from Texas, the location,
the source where these migrants came from.
Speaker 2: When we are opening up a case with
an investigation with regard to the suspected
activities involving the 48 migrants from
Venezuela, that as we understand it at this point,
the facts of the case at this point are that on
Wednesday, September 14th, here in Bear County,
in the city of San Antonio, our understanding is
that a Venezuelan migrant was paid what we would
call a bird dog fee to recruit approximately
50 migrants from the area around a migrant
resource center on San Pedro here in San Antonio.
Speaker 1: You know, they talk about Democrats
as the criminals. This is this is just
straight up criminality. If it's as alleged.
Speaker 2: As we understand it, 48 migrants
were lured. I will use the word lured under
false pretenses into into staying at a hotel for
a couple of days. They were taken by airplane.
At a certain point, they were shuttled to an
airplane where they were flown to Florida and then
eventually flown to Martha's Vineyard. Again under
false pretenses is the information that we have
that they were promised work, they were promised
the solution to several of their problems. They
were taken to Martha's Vineyard. From what? For
what we can gather for nothing for little more
than a photo op video up. And then they were
unceremoniously stranded in Martha's Vineyard.
What infuriates me the most about this case is
that here we have 48 people that are already
on on hard times. Right. They are here
legally in our country at that point.
They have every right to be where they are.
Speaker 1: Now, remember that that's this is an
important detail. The right has been just using
the blanket term illegal immigrants. These are
folks, as I understand it, and as it seems like
the sheriff understands it as well. And we'll see
if he even explains this. Who were in the process
of having asylum asylum claims reviewed. Meaning
that at this particular point in time, these
were not individuals subject to deportation for
illegal immigration. This is an important detail.
Speaker 2: And I believe that they were preyed
upon. Somebody came from out of state, preyed upon
these people, lured them with promises of a better
life, which is what they were absolutely
looking for. And with the knowledge that
they were going to cling to whatever hope they
could, they could be offered for a better life,
to just be exploited and hoodwinked
into making this trip to Florida and
then onward to Martha's Vineyard for what
I believe to be nothing more than political
posturing to make a point. Well, look, we
all know that during a political campaign,
things can get nasty. Things can get out of hand.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So the point here is criminal
investigation is starting and we're going
to follow it very closely. Now, this may
not be the only criminal investigation into Ron
DeSantis, a stunt and I say investigate criminally
in all jurisdictions where this stunt extended
its tentacles. Business Insider reporting. A
massachusetts state lawmaker representing Martha's
Vineyard is seeking a federal trafficking probe,
human trafficking probe after DeSantis relocated
migrants to the island. This article, again from
Business Insider, says State Representative
Dylan Fernandez, a Democrat representing
Martha's Vineyard, called on the Justice
Department to launch a probe after DeSantis
chartered two planes for more than $600,000
in taxpayer dollars to transport 50 migrants
from Texas to the island last Wednesday. Multiple
criminal investigations being requested, and that
is exactly what needs to happen now. The truth
again, I hate to have to be so apparently cynical.
But much like I've said, if you're waiting for the
Trump in an orange jumpsuit behind bars moment.
You're going to be waiting a very long time. I
don't think there is any chance that DeSantis goes
to prison for what he did, particularly when he's
the governor. And while the buck stops with him,
the actual acts were carried out and logistically
organized by people under DeSantis. I get it,
guys. The buck stops with him, and that's
ultimately where it's where it should stop.
If we're waiting around for dissenters to end
up in prison, I think we're sort of putting the
target a bit too high. However, is it possible
that this stunt and all of the negative publicity
that's coming with it, I mean, there's positive
publicity as well from the right, although some
on the right aren't pleased. But will the negative
publicity that's coming for it from it maybe hurt
DeSantis in his imminent reelection campaign in
Florida, where, as we talked about on the bonus
show yesterday, DeSantis is currently winning by
about an average of four or five against Charlie
Crist, maybe. I think that's that's the optimistic
scenario, not that the Santos ends up in prison,
by the way. If you did what was done,
except it was with young girls to lure
them into prostitution, you damn well could
end up in prison. But this is different. This
is the Republican governor of Florida.
But be that as it is. Be that as it may,
whichever is your preference. I think the
best case scenario here is this hurts the
Santos reelection campaign. And he's, as of
right now, looking like he's going to sail
to that reelection. At least there's a criminal
investigation. We'll leave it there for today.